on the way upstairs to bed my son kept
sneezing and sneezing we brought him
down and noticed he had a little
something in his nose oh that's not cool
alright y'all so on the show we have a
segment called hashtag Disick toddlers
where parents share their wildest
toddler stories so whose lipstick is
that I'm mine you bought it what where'd
you buy that my epic yeah
I find it from Home Depot today we
decided to get real like super real like
real gross and we asked y'all on the
Internet to tell us your messiest most
disgusting toddler moment I haven't seen
any of these responses yet so let's get
grossed out together shall we
[Music]
[Laughter]
she she said she was ready for bed with
her sleep mask that she found and that
is a definite a pad that's a pad on her
daughter's which by the way a
little-known fact that I don't know if
I've shared before it didn't know this
was a pad knows little kid okay use it
as a band-aid I needed a rather large
bandage and that's what I use it as mom
got so pissed because I wasted it but I
thought it was band-aid I didn't know my
five-year-old son decided his
two-year-old sister needed desitin all
over her the morning of her birthday
party that is so nasty but you know it's
worth walking in and your son that's
right Remy calling you out for the
future when you're 20 and this comes
back to haunt you
playing in his poop Betty found in his
diaper and it has rubbed in kind of like
so except for it was a round crib and it
was all the way around it yep it was not
cool it was not that was the time I was
like why couldn't have been my nanny's
time to come in and get him like why was
it mine anyway that stinks
my granddaughter wanted to put on
lipstick this is how she came out of the
bathroom this has been my daughter as
well yep that's my my River just like I
look pretty yes you do baby that's
awesome it kind of looks like Gary the
you know horror film but it's fine y'all
my kid dress is chunky and Chuckie chunk
very different films Goonies y'all my
kid dressed is chugging asked if I
wanted to play she also loves to get up
in the middle of the night and make
hellacious messes out of anything she
can find more kitchen picks if you dare
she's kind of scary
that's scary we did one on scary that's
scary
oh-ho she just walks into her parents
room and it's just like wanna play and
like that's like a fake nothing when my
daughter was three she pooped in her
shoe and brought the shoe to me like as
an offering like the three wisemen
that's awesome like and every new that's
amazing poop man there are so many poop
stories when you're kids
it's crazy my daughter Sammi climbed in
my bed with Nesquik powder and a fork
when I was in the shower
oh my sheets were white it was
everywhere and she denied doing it even
while licking her best part is the
denial I've done that with my kids too I
was like I know you ate the Oreo because
it's in your mouth like right now the
other day while at the grocery store my
daughter pointed at my face and said
mommy boo boo I told her no but she
insisted mommy boo boo before trying to
kiss it and make it all better the red
spot was a breakout how started to get
not sure which is worse her trying to
kiss a zit or her yelling while pointing
it out to everyone
my daughter has also done that I had a
zit on my face like as if I were in
junior high again and it was big and she
thought I had a boo-boo it was it it was
called the zit she goes with it and she
was so grossed out by was like can't
even know to be grossed out by it but
the word does sound gross whatever
after dinner on my way upstairs to bed
my son Oh on the way upstairs to bed my
son kept sneezing and sneezing we
brought him down and noticed he had a
little something in his nose oh that's
not cool we pulled out a five inch piece
of spaghetti that somehow he inhaled at
dinner while we were laughing and
fooling around at the table now see I
don't think the zipping is gross but I
think that is gnarly that grosses me out
not then you know in doctors like do
nasal spray like if you're having like
sinus problems no I say no
my daughter poured an entire bottle of
pancake syrup over her hand and body
okay she had jeans on that way we had oh
you did cut them off because they were
sticking to her oh that's like that
gypsy that friends episode with bras he
was in like he was trapped in the
bathroom and he was like I can't get the
the leather pants back on or something
and he was baby powder everywhere this
is sticking it's making a paste it was
awesome when my son was three he came
running out of the bathroom and
excitement and yelled my poop just
exploded like a party that might be a
case of the runs I don't know what's
having there if it's exploding that's
not good all right well I'm officially
grossed out and I love it good job
people I always want to hear about the
crazy things your kids are doing so find
me on Twitter Facebook and Instagram and
use the hashtag hashtag because toddlers
to tell me your story and maybe I'll
rejoice next time only if it's Krishna
okay subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going